What's up, guys? So today because you asked
for it we are going to be learning English with
Imagine Dragons and we have chosen four songs
for you it was really difficult because there
are so many great ones but the ones that we will
learn within this lesson are Believer, Thunder,
Radioactive and Demons and in fact we have another
lesson with a fifth song but you'll find that only
over on our Instagram so I highly recommend that
you go check that out after you finish this lesson
so let's start off with the first song Believer
so first you are going to listen to the song with
subtitles and then we will teach you all the
most important vocabulary and pronunciation.
So most learners think that they can't
understand natives because we speak too fast
but actually the bigger problem is that we cut and
connect our words in surprising ways like you've
just seen here and they probably didn't teach
you this in school and that is exactly why in our
three-part masterclass we will teach you the three
principles to be able to understand natives at any
speed and that is pronunciation, vocabulary and
cultural context the best part is you can try it
absolutely free click up here or down description
below and you can learn more and sign up now!
Hey, do you want to learn the
English that natives really use
like in your favorite songs? Well I
have this lesson on our other channel
where I teach you the English that
natives really use in our everyday life
not like you learned in school and you can check
that out after you finish this lesson by clicking
up here or down the description below now let's
start learning with our next song Radioactive.
Alright guys we're almost done I just wanted
to remind you that if you cannot get enough
of Imagine Dragons we have another lesson
with their song Bad Liar just over on our
Instagram so I highly recommend that you
check that out after you finish your test.
Awesome work today, guys! Now we made this lesson
today with Imagine Dragons because you guys
asked us for it so if there's any other musical
groups that you would love to learn with then why
don't you let me know down in the comments below
and maybe we'll make our next lesson with it.
Alright guys and now it's time to go beyond
the classroom and live your English, aww yeah!